in the world's largest refugee
settlement anxiety and alarm as Hamidah
hutou clutches her prayer beads
she also clings to her faith we've heard
the coronavirus has occurred in Malaysia
Mecca and Thailand now we've heard it
has spread in Bangladesh and we're
praying to God to save us around 1
million refugees live in these informal
settlements in Cox's Bazaar where
sanitation has always been an issue and
living conditions are so crowded that
social distancing is impossible
authorities are using loudspeakers in
some parts of the camps to give advice
on how to prevent the spread of Kovach
19 but humanitarian groups say it's not
enough the Rohini medics organization
warns a corona virus outbreak in this
community could lead to an enormous loss
of life and it's been producing
informational videos in the rahega
language and posting them online but
last September Bangladesh is government
shut down most of the internet and
telecommunication networks in and around
the camps unfortunately don't have the
access so we are doing our best and it's
really frustrating for us that we are
not reaching the targeted population
aid groups and NGOs are urging
government officials to reverse their
decision should immediately let the
internet restrictions so that refugees
have information and are able to inform
themselves about how to mitigate the
risk of a corona virus spread in the
camps the government hasn't responded to
calls to restore the internet but says
all measures it's taken to prevent an
outbreak have been necessary we have
ordered the shutdown of places where
people usually gather including schools
madrasahs Learning Center's etc only
Essential Commodities will be continued
in the camps Amnesty International says
the lack of internet access in
Bangladesh and other parts of the world
is making the situation worse
on telecommunication because that's
that's the easiest and fastest source of
disseminating information that needs to
be provided to this vulnerable RO hanga
activists have been holding seminars to
educate other refugees about a threat
unlike any they faced before having
escaped violence now doing all they can
to evade a virus Mohammed jim-jim al
Jazeera Phil Robertson with us now
deputy director of Human Rights Watch
Asia Asia division he's on skype from
Bangkok Phil we focused so much on
social distancing and when I looked at
those pictures there it's that it's
impossible it is absolutely impossible
to think about that have you got any
thoughts on what can be done well the
most important thing for the Bangladesh
government to do now is turn on the
internet for the raw anger refugees in
those refugee camps so that they're able
to communicate with humanitarians and
and with other persons about what is
happening and get accurate information
I mean it's astonishing the kind of
restrictions we're seeing on those camps
especially in this time of a pandemic
that's gonna threaten the health of so
many you know when you look at those
camps as you said there's no social
distancing you talked about washing your
hands but you know often access to water
is limited you know it's a disaster
waiting to happen it's an absolute
tinderbox where Koba 19 so again I take
your point about what the what the
Bangladesh government could do in the
internet is very important for
information and communication but I'm
just thinking about sort of practical
things which could happen now I know
there's people trying to supply aid and
sanitation services is there anything
more which which can be done on that
level well I mean the government of
Bangladesh should allow for the Rohingya
groups to do information campaigns about
how to prevent transmission of kovat 19
what has been happening is that the
Bangladesh officials have been saying no
to those kind of campaigns unless
they're running them themselves and
people need to be able to get the
information but the
the government claims that such
campaigns would would prompt panic the
real panic is going to come from people
who don't know what the situation is and
they have no information about what
kovat 19 is or how to stop it you know
the government is not allowing people to
use the internet so that coordinated
efforts could be taken under by
humanitarians on public health issues
you can't even call the government
hotline from the camps if you want to be
referred to a government hospital you
know they're trying to do things in the
camps with both hands tied behind their
back are you and other groups in direct
contact with the Bangladesh government
over this the Bangladesh government
unfortunately has not been listening to
NGOs and to other governments about this
issue of the internet access and the
health crisis in the camps you know I
think that there has to be a greater
pressure put on the Bangladesh
government to realize that this is a
wrongheaded policy that has to stop
otherwise there may be a very grave
tragedy that occurs in the camps of the
row Inga phil robertson
from Human Rights Watch I'm glad we
could talk to you about this it is very
important of course to keep these issues
in the spotlight in these times thank
you thank you very much